I'm not like a dude who's attached to my
like you know like me and my family
or Indian either I don't I have a lot of
problems with like I think because I'm
mixed race I just don't give a [__]
about any of that stuff she's not she's
not Indian they met on in the personal
ads and went out on a few dates had me
out of it we're never married or
anything personally out of the paperback
yeah the paper the old school Craigslist
yeah my aunt apparently was supposed to
meet this dude and she had so many dates
from the personal ads she dumped him off
under my mom is that right yeah yeah
this is your biological biological
dumped your aunt was like I got too much
of mine too many take this yeah and it
turned into you turned into me yeah
yeah a weird little piece of print in
the newspaper
a weird desperate Indian man in the
newspaper like please with anyone [__]
the Honeydew with Ryan